name from me and thank you christos
and hopefully we're going to get more
people
to join and
i will start and i will talk about two
things as christo said i will talk about
the purpose and the usefulness of
forecasting
it's basically an applied data science
field
and i'll talk about the contribution of
the m competitions
m stands for my last name agreed is the
first letter for my last name
and i'm the organizer and as i'm going
to talk the first competition was done
in 1980
so it has a long history and now we're
going to do the sixth competition
okay
maybe you have heard about the great
toilet paper scarcity
that happened about a year ago
and as you can see on the left here the
people
bought all of the toilet paper there
were some
newspaper stories that would be
scarcity in total toilet paper people
were like crazy to buy for a few years
not just for a few months
and that's what happened okay
and you couldn't find toilet paper for a
long time
that's how it looked like the demand for
toilet paper was going
but nicely
after the 10th of
the 11th of march and then on the 12th
of march went to the sky
then slowly went back to normal
now this is a big forecasting failure
but hopefully but interestingly it's
very difficult to
predict it
[Music]
and the question that which shows the
value of forecast
is how often you should be to a shoppers
to a supermarket or
to some other places to find what you
want to buy and you could
find it
so basically what is the role of
forecasting
is to make sure that in a big store like
the walmart
that they have up to 200 000 items
that the customers that they're going to
go and they're going to
look for some specific item they're
going to find it
and walmart is one of the biggest if not
the biggest forecaster user in the world
they have close to 12 000 stores
there are about 200 thousand items per
store
and every week they do 2.3 million
forecasts
so it's a big science behind the
forecasting
and it's not the only company that does
that
target is another very big forecasting
user
they have
a lot of stores also
and basically what they're doing
they have a very elaborate forecasting
system
and they do one billion
weekly forecasts okay
so there is a lot behind when you go to
a supermarket
and you find what you want to find
there's a big science behind it to make
sure that
what you want to buy it's going to be
there and very often we have scarcities
like the toilet paper scarcity or some
other scarcities of this type so how do
we forecast
forecast by finding data
this is the airline passengers in
australia as you can see it's a very
nicely behaving series it has a
very constant smooth trend
and a lot of seasonality
the highest is in the beginning
of the year in january after christmas
in australia it's summer so
the summer months there's a bigger
demand
and then the airline passengers go down
in the winter months of australia
now even if you take a good artist you
can
find the continuation of this pattern so
the idea then for forecasting is we find
collect data past data
and then we use some method be able to
extrapolate
and in this particular case going to
extrapolate the trend
and it's going to extrapolate the
sonality
now there are different ways of
forecasting
there are different lists so
sorry there's a part here that
i i don't know how to
okay sorry
okay so there are different ways to
forecast there are different types of
forecasting
this one is high blood pressure pills
the demand for this is very constant
there's very little
fluctuations for instance people who
have high blood pressure they can take a
pill every day
so the demand and the forecasting for
high blood
high blood pressure pills is constant
it's very easy to forecast another easy
item to focus is milk
it doesn't cost very much in particular
for people have children
they have to buy it every day
so again there is
very constant demand and very little
fluctuation
now if you take meat this is another
type of forecasting
the fluctuation here is much wider
from day to day and there is a lot of
competition between different types of
meat for instance
chickens or porks or beef
or different kinds
so how they manage to do it by giving a
lot of
coupons making price
discounts providing price discounts and
doing
a lot of marketing to promote one type
of
meat versus another so here then the
demand will
be will
be depending on several factors
and one of the big factors would be
price the other would be promotions
the other would be advertising another
type of forecasting is fashion
here one cannot have a lot of
historical data because the fashion
changes
and the success of selling fashion items
is how well the people are going to
like them and buy them another type
would be computers laptop computers for
instance
or smart tvs here a lot of
the demand for these items would depend
on the technological innovation
depend on the prices depend on different
factors
that for instance the milk or the meat
another type of items is luxury items
the demand here is very sporadic
for instance half of the sales of
this type of item will be at christmas
for instance mother day
and things like this so here there are a
lot of peaks
and then there is close to zero
so it's a very different type of demand
and
the challenge to forecast this is very
different
than forecasting milk or meat
and lastly
automobiles it's a very expensive item
and it's influenced a great deal by what
happens to the economy
to give you an example this is the
the estimated change for automobiles
here there was a great depression the
great recession
the 2007-2009 and you see how much it
here is what happened after
the corona virus so here the
demand is influenced a great deal
about what helps the economy and what
happens
to the general environment like here now
the the coronavirus
there's a very big drop in demand
for one reason these people drive much
less and the other is
a lot of people don't have enough money
to buy a car
so the field then of forecasting
is concerned with all types of
forecasting
and the idea is for each one we have
would be a very different way
to forecast it and to depend on very
different factors
so other areas except retail forecasting
products forecasting that we're all used
to it's energy forecasting
electricity consumption and prices are
very important
and now there's a lot of forecasting
in renewable energy winds and
photovoltaic
for for companies that they produce
electricity for instance
they don't want to produce too much
because if it is
produced and it's not used they're going
to
have resources wasted fuel wasted
and their met don't make enough money
this is an example of
electricity prices
and we have a lot of data and that's
where we're using a lot of
machine learning and learning methods to
forecasting
here we have no trend we have multiple
seasonal patterns
there are the the seasonal pattern is
different dash of the week there are
different
the demand changes there's more for
instance on fridays
and on mondays that days on saturdays
there is the hourly
changes for instance in the morning and
in the evening
and there are different seasonal
patterns and the whole idea then of
the forecasting method is to be able to
identify
all of these partners and uh predict
them
and they're doing a lot of work and
there's a a great jobs being done
now there's another area which is a lot
of forecasting in the financial area
in stocks boards and currencies this is
an example
of stock prices
there is a phenomenal constant
trend and because here it's an
algorithmic trend
this trend is exponential and there are
huge fluctuations around the trend
for instance in here
that was before the great
recession the standard 500
index was 240.
here it went to 928
and then now is 3500 so
in the in terms of the long-term trend
there is a great
stability
the real increases adjust for inflation
it's 4.1 every year
if you include dividends is 8.7 percent
and if you if you don't take
real but you take current prices it's 11
so on the average the prices increase
close to 11 every year however there are
huge fluctuations in july 2000
it was 2240
eight years later a little less than
eight years later it went down to
928 so there was a huge decrease
huge fluctuations huge uncertainty and
then from march
2008 to today to
last month or
there was an increase of 280 percent
so huge fluctuations very consistent
trend
and these are the type of things we try
to learn from forecasting
okay try to learn how the data behaves
what's going to happen and how we can
understand as much about this data as
possible
there are other areas that we do a lot
of forecasting
online sales there's a big thing now
with online sales
google trends visitors
or users in social media social sites
online advertising revenues for the
companies that they're
in the social sites
and airline passengers okay so
and there are more areas but this is
a summary of the different areas we do a
lot a lot of forecasting
so here for instance if i take a
forecasting method
and i stop in 2018
and i focus for the next year these are
my 12 forecasts
and as you see it's a pretty good
forecast
now tell you some of the problems with
forecasting and again
this is something that one cannot
predict that's what happens if i had to
focus
in 2019 2020
because of the coronal virus airline
passengers went to
practically zero so my focus was lousy
so forecasting then it's very accurate
as long as past pattern and past
relationships
remain constant however like what
happens
the pandemic cannot work as well because
the patterns and the relationships
change and they
can change very drastically
so that would be then a failure of
forecasting but
again this failure shows that most of
the time
you can forecast pretty accurately
now you remember the even green sheep
that got stuck in the
stretch canal now even
one accident like this can create
problems with the supply chain
and you can have difficulties
in predicting for instance what would be
the price of coffee or the price of even
toilet paper because they may be
scarcity because of even
one single event
so to come and summarize what is the
value
and the contribution of forecasting
the idea the objectives the purpose
is to predict as accurately as possible
future events
in order to improve the decisions about
this event
for instance a very
concrete example for forecasting would
be a supermarket
predict how many bots of a certain kind
of milk
customers are going to demand tomorrow
so that's
a major thing about forecasting
now in addition however forecasting has
two parts
one is to predict something as accurate
as possible
and the other is to say that look
none of my predictions would be perfect
so i have to estimate what would be the
uncertainty around these predictions
in other words i can say okay the most
likely
number for milk tomorrow for a certain
time would be 55
bottles but i know it's not going to be
perfect
so i can say that's going to be between
45 and 65 bottles
and this is then how we estimate
uncertainty
and our forecasting methods do both
things
they both forecast the most likely
number
and then they give me a range about the
uncertainty the most likely uncertainty
and having them the most accurate number
of forecasts
or the most likely in the uncertainty
then we can put them together we can
estimate
we can balance the opportunity cost and
the opportunity losses
come up with how many bottles of meals
you sell knowing that
if a particular with milk has
dates that they cannot sell it
afterwards
then we can decide what would be the
most
what would be the most logical or the
most
the optimal number of
milks put on the surface of the
supermarket
okay so this is what is forecasting
and what i'm going to like to talk now
is what
the contributions of the m competitions
to improve the forecasting and like you
we have all of the data is open source
they're available easily available in
github
anybody can go and find them anybody can
use them
and they're completely free to be used
okay and these forecasting competitions
have
received a lot of attention
and they have improved greatly in the
field of forecasting
and as i told you before we have done
five already
and we're in the process of designing
the new one the sixth one
the sixth one i'm going to say a few
things at the end
okay so what forecaster competitions are
of the equivalent of laboratory
experimentations
so we try to get empirical evidence
by doing these competitions
and they provide an objective and
empirical
evidence about the most accurate
forecasting method
the most appropriate way to estimate
uncertainty
trying to find the forecasting value
added
and since we know the cost of running
different methods then we can decide
how which is
the most appropriate method for a
situation
so with all of these then we offer a lot
of information to prove the theory in
the practice of forecasting
so what we have learned from these
competitions
we have we know that we can explain the
past
very well the child the challenge is to
predict the future
and we're doing a lot of work on that
and i'm going to talk a little about
this
what we have found out that there is no
any model which is the best model
but what we do is we
predict we we identify
and we estimate a lot of models and then
we find the average of those models
and we know that now that machine
learning and deep learning
they improve forecasting accuracy and
there's a big big effort
to develop methods which are based on
the machine learning
this is what we use before which were
statistical methods
that they were accurate after a certain
point but now the machine learning
the further they're more accurate
what we are not sure about is how to
predict things in non-stable
environments
like now with the pandemic
since the pandemic
lasts for only a year and it's not
regular we don't have enough historical
information
to know what could reach its influence
what we are not sure is what's the
performance of human versus models
a lot of forecasts are done just
mentally
the models provide objective information
and we find out that very often
the models are more accurate than humans
and
what is the value of explanatory
variables like the price
influences the sales of a product
however we may know what are the price
the past price but we don't know what
are the future prices
because competitors can decrease the
price and we may have to decrease the
price
or something may happen that will oblige
us to
increase the price the same thing is
true with advertising
and with all of the other variables that
will explanatory
that they help us forecast the
future of demand
now what we don't know we don't know
two things about uncertainty
uncertainty in statistics very often we
have been told that it's
nice and behaved and it's normally
distributed well that's not true
very often uncertainty is far tails
like what is happening now with the
pandemic
and there are black swans things we
cannot predict
we can ex understand what happens in the
past
we can explain the past but we cannot
find causalities
and we have a lot of difficulties
separating large
from skills okay
so the first competition as i told you
was done in the early 80s
it was published in 1982 and what we
found out in this
first first competition was not
statistically sophisticated or complex
methods
were not more accurate than very simple
ones
statisticians didn't like that at that
time i did like i was a statistician at
that time
and i didn't like this but that's what
we found
and this is an example of what we found
the the first one here it's a very very
simple
statistical method this is a very very
sophisticated the box check is a very
sophisticated statistical method
well it was much less accurate
the simple method was much much much by
2.5 percent more accurate than the
sophisticated
one it was a little better for one two
periods ahead
but on the average it was less accurate
than this simple method
statisticians i told you they did like
that
this was another example
of this box jackets methods versus
a very simple
statistical one and on the average as
you can see
apart from period one that was more
accurate in all of the others was less
accurate
than the sophisticated better than the
simple one the second finding
is that the accuracy of the variant
methods if we combine them
together i i it was more accurate i
would perform the average
of individual methods so the
taking the average forecast of more than
one method
improve the accuracy versus the simple
versus this
individual methods and there was a big
argument with statisticians at that time
because they thought that this the best
for each time series is a best model
that was not the case and the last thing
which was equally important was the
uncertainty
of combining was lower than the
uncertainty of individual methods
so these were the three major things
that we found in them
one competition
them two competition was
between statistical methods
and forecasters and
were told that forecasters would do
better than the statistical methods
when we found out that it was not the
case and we had five human forecasters
and their accuracy was lower than the
statistical methods
these are two very very simple
statistical methods
on the average there was 11.9 and 12.6
their accuracy
this is the sophisticated method much
much worse
and these are the five forecasters none
of the forecasts
did better than the simple list of
statistical methods
so this tell us something about
the value of the judgment of forecasters
okay so what we know
we know that when people do judgmental
forecasts
very often they're not better than if we
take
what we call a naive benchmark in other
words
saying that tomorrow the sales and the
day after tomorrow would be like today
and 52 of the time
three thousand three hundred thousand
forecasts were less
accurate than the benchmark
when people went forecasters
and people and managers they adjust the
statistical
forecast often they don't improve
their their accuracy and in order to do
it they have to do
the adjustment objectively and
systematically
and they have to concentrate on large
changes very often they make small
improvements what they think is one
improvements and actually they don't
they are not improvements
they have to justify the reasons for the
adjustments
preferably written and anonymously they
don't like to do that
when they do it they improve
their adjustments then we have to keep
track of the adjustments to evaluate
their contribution
and avoiding upward adjustments very
often
the adjustments that they do they are on
the positive side
they think that they can improve because
things are going to become better and
very often that's not
what is happening okay
now the third competition
was much bigger from 1000 series we had
in
m1 we went to 3 300.
here now we did a nice
sampling in terms of different
domains micro data industry macro
finance demographic
etc and different frequencies
yearly quarterly monthly numbers and
then we found the accuracy
of each one of them and it was a
very big improvement this type of
providing this type of information
to forecasters
now what we found
in from the m1 and m2
was a new method called theta
that was that was a variation of
exponential smoothing
would be the most accurate by some small
amount
here this this was the accuracy of uh
over naive two of theta
two point five percent however the
combining
which was these three messages three
exponential smooth method was two
percent
so the improvement was half of a percent
so it was an improvement but not very
big improvement
okay
now the m4 competition was much bigger
we went from 3000 series
to 100 000 series by
this time that was done in 2018
computers were much bigger
much faster we would
accommodate much more data to do the
competition
again we did a nice sampling
in terms of data having micro data
industry and so on
and having different frequencies here we
went
in addition to monthly that was in the
m3
went to weekly to daily and to hourly
and we have a very big sample of time
series
and the information we got it was much
more
accurate this time because it was much
wider and we had many more cities
and we had people participating from all
over the world
now i'm not going to go through the
seven
findings i guess
you can get this information from
other places but
the finding that we found and it
continues to be
correct in all of the competitions the
past and the futures
is the improved accuracy of combining
before them competitions the
statisticians believe
that there is a best model for every
time series well we found that that's
nonsense that's actually the more modern
combined the better is the accuracy and
the smaller is the uncertainty
and this finding becomes
even more important now in the deep
learning models that they use
for very important forecasting
applications
they estimate up to 200 or 300 models
and they take they take the median of
them and they found out that this was
that this is the most accurate
prediction
in the coronavirus forecast that they
did
or or they're still doing they
again finding out that the best forecast
is if you take the average of all of the
forecasts done by different legends
so that was the most important finding
now in the m4 competition
the winning method was a hybrid approach
that utilized statistical and and
machine learning features
and this basically method this method
this hybrid method that
continued to exist now and has been
continued with m5 competition
made a big difference in forecasting
accuracy
now another thing that we found with the
m4 competition
that the precision of the prediction
intervals of the uncertainty
improve considerably
okay
and several other things that i'm going
to talk about
when i go to the m5 competition okay
now what the m up to m4
we had a long forecasting winter there
was
small improvements in accuracy between
the different methods
the m3 the theater but it was actually
small
okay
nothing big nothing no breakthroughs
there was also a problem with
estimating uncertainty that in all of
the three competitions was
underestimated significantly
and there was basically no new exciting
method in the m1 m2 and m3
now then four edit all of these
by this new method that was introduced
by a guy
called slaux mill who used to work at
this time
for uber and basically
provided a significant increase
in accuracy
all of this information has been put
into a
volume into a special issue of the
international general forecast
which you can find if you're interested
and here's something like 35
articles that they explain them for
competition
in details and they provide guidance
to both researchers and business people
of what methods to use and how to use it
and provide an incentive of which way
the theory is forecasting just to go
through
and a lot of these papers in this issue
are open access so
if you put my name and you can find them
you can get them for free
okay now this is the
main absolute percent as error this is
the computer time
and the more computer time one spends
it seems that the accuracy improves
this is the method the winning method
okay and the time that it took
to run it
now then five competition the m1 m3 and
m4
m2 was a special one because it was a
budget forecasting
competition with
live forecasters so
they covered practically every frequency
and domain
the m5 was a special case it was
a hierarchical daily retailing data
exhibiting intermittency
so here was at the level of the item
skus and then going all the way
to the sales of the company for three
states the data was given to us by
walmart
there was something like 43 000 series
and it was hierarchical and the
and that's what how forecasting is done
in the retailing industry
now intermittent demand
is like this as you see there are a lot
of zeros and then
spikes lumpy demand again a lot of
zeros and then some big
spikes smooth series
and erratic so the data the 42 000
time series that we had buying these
four types of data
the m5 was the first competition to
study uncertainty
details we had two tracks we had two
challenges one was
who would focus the most accurately the
data
and the other is who would focus
uncertainty most accurately
now the first and most important finding
which statistical methods were not as
accurate
anymore as machine learning methods
again we found that the value of
combining all of the top methods
not only the the best one but all of the
top methods were using combining
another thing that was started in the m4
was cross learning instead of trying to
find
the accuracy by looking at each one of
the series
we try to find out the accuracy by using
all of the series together
the idea of course learning
now another
innovation in the m4 and in the m5
competition
instead of using all of the data to find
the best model
we use part of the data we separate the
data into two parts
one being testing part
and the one being the validation part
and the other being the testing part so
we use part of the data
to make a model and then we test the
model on the future
the data we didn't use to
develop the model and then we did this
on a rolling basis
and this cross-validation then avoided
overfitting that was the problem with
the previous
statistical methods
there was a very big difference then in
the m5 between the winning methods and
the statistical benchmarks
and for uh we found
that some extraordinary variables like
christmas or like labor day or like
big days
like days that they attract a lot of
people
can be used to explain and some
explanatory
variables like in the united states they
give food stamps
and when they're when they there were
these stumps given
then there was the they can explain very
much what happened to the cells
so this was then the m5 competition
now to summarize them
competitions destroy three major
forecasting meets
that is the best model that is not just
a single best model
forecasting
we improve accuracy by combining models
in addition to improving accuracy we
reduce the variance of the uncertainty
of the forecasting
the future is never a perfect
continuation of the past
so instead of overfeeding we use
cross-validation to make
our best model and instead of using
each series separately to find to
determine the accuracy of all of the
models we use then the idea of cross
learning to improve overall likelihood
this is not always all of the series
so combining cross-validation and
cross-learning added the
long-forecasting winter
and got us considered considerable
improvements in focusing accuracy
so this is a summary of the five
m competitions and the last one that i'm
doing right now
is a financial competition
seven months interval and it's going to
ask for just mental levels in other
words they're not the
forecasters are not going to use only
quantitative information
but they're going to use also their
judgment about what
message or rather what stocks
buy
so after now there have been 18
forecasting competitions that will be
the last one
and as you can see it will cover much
wider
topics to test
and thank you i think i did
how we're going to go thank you very
much i think uh now if
anyone has questions please uh you can
open your mic
and just ask or raise your hand
and again open your mic if you don't ask
maybe i can't with one question sure
it's related to the competition uh so
i assume that the i mean the normal way
to
you know test and you know solve the
challenges in in forecasting or any
other field would be
i mean through i mean through the
research
avenue i guess so um i would say that
the competitions provided another way to
uh
kind of accelerate right the yeah
[Music]
a laboratory laboratory experimentation
provides
reach and objective evidence
to charge the value of the different
methods the accuracy of the
uncertainties
and what i mean how how does i mean how
does the let's say the forecasting
community
let's react i mean with this competition
in terms of
um i mean following the practices let's
say that
we're uh i mean proven let's say in
these competitions
well in the beginning they were not very
pleased because the statisticians
they thought their message their
sophisticated messages
should be the best and then when they
find out that
objective empirical evidence saw
they were very upset
now they have been accepted now
in the m competitions is probably
the most cited
articles in the forecasting literature
yes of course of course that's uh i i
kind of see it as a kind of a disrupting
way to
move let's say things forward like in in
another way
well yeah yes and sometimes the
disruptive race is
the most useful because
finds the direction
like now nobody questions anymore the
value of combining
and as i told you in the deep learning
so it's not it's not anymore question
the value of the competitions
at some point there's a lot of questions
in the last in the m5 with some like 7
000
yeah i think um just
just um one one small comment i think
there is some some
problem with your sound sometimes we can
at least i cannot hear you very very
well okay
let me try to come closer okay maybe
yeah no it's
better okay
[Music]
i think i saw nicosia the question
because
hello professor hello and thank you very
much for your
talk it was a pleasure here you again
i'd like to ask something about the
uncertainty
if i understood well you taught us that
at the m4 competition the methods
underestimate the uncertainty
up to m4 after one m2 and m3 they
understand uncertainty
in them for the two top methods
they they were perfect estimating
uncertainty
the others did not do very well in them
five
they did they learn
best message to them for and the
estimate uncertainty correctly
okay okay and
i saw the results of the m5 and the xg
boost was the best one i think the the
first and this yeah
yeah the first and the second and
most of the top methods were machine
learning
okay yeah and the one
last question is the certainty you
measure it like
a standard deviation or um uncertainty
yeah it's based on the on some form of
standard deviation yes okay
thanks okay and we have another question
from max
um i think he just answered the question
um i thanks for the presentation
and a great overview i'm coming from a
humanities background and also at the
same question
what exactly does it mean to predict
uncertainty but i think he
him he just answered this question well
uncertainty he needed to make decisions
like in the inventory example i told you
you have to balance what would be the
course of throw away a bottle of milk
that you don't
that you have in the shelf and you don't
sell versus
what's going to happen if some customer
comes to buy a certain bottle of
building
and he or she cannot find it and
that's a typical example
okay using uncertainty
make decisions
thank you thanks thank you
are there any more questions i think we
have time for another one and then we
we have to proceed to the next talk
okay then um thanks again professor van
grieves
you're it was very very interesting to
to see such a
um such a kind of dense overview of of
the field
thank you thank you okay so bye bye
bye bye
psy are you are you in the